frédéric viala et je restais auteurs du
manifeste contre les accords
transatlantique aux éditions eric
bonnier selon lui le nouvel accord ne
change pas à grand chose
la réalité c'est que le nouvel accord le
nouvel à l'ena a été essentiellement
voulue par donald trump pour des motifs
électoraux
il s'agit en fait pour lui de bien
montrer aux américains que il a tout
fait pour protéger les les emplois
américains notamment dans l'industrie et
donc il ya simplement un certain nombre
de dispositions qui sont prévus dans
l'accord pour augmenter les tarifs
douaniers sur l'aluminium sur l'acier
sur les voitures et en contrepartie les
le canada et le mexique ont obtenu que
soit supprimée le mécanisme d'arbitrage
pour le reste il s'agit pratiquement la
même chose c'est-à-dire d'un accord de
libre échange qui permet aux entreprises
de continuer de faire ce qu'elles
veulent ou à peu près et dans les
conditions qui les intéressent sur les 3
sur les trois pays